à vénissieux maintenant la plupart des
écoles primaires et maternelles de la
ville étaient en grève aujourd'hui
un mouvement qui l'a aussi veut
protester contre le vandalisme et
l'insécurité qui règne dès les petites
classes en fait une manifestation qui
dit où est clair le ras-le-bol des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves
agnès garder france veillant une journée
100 x vol pour une école sans violence
les enfants des minguettes ont manifesté
aujourd'hui pour la première fois de
leur vie avec parents et enseignants ont
tous excédé par un quotidien fait de
casse et de peur pratiquement toutes les
femmes parce que avant de commencer la
semaine il faut nettoyer toutes les
cochonneries qui ont été 7 le week-end
avant de le jeune tout sa cavale et
seront franchement j'ai peur parce que
voilà les couples hâle pour dire le
moins
nouvelle grande j'ai été tendue peu
attention les fréquentations leur marche
a pris fin dans sept écoles primaires
l'école jean-moulin l'une des plus
anciennes du quartier des minguettes
l'une des plus exposées aussi les maires
des villes messieurs s'y est rendu pour
un côté les doléances des uns et des
autres pas de discours
le constat des parents simplement dur à
entendre
c'est la morale qui recule quand vous je
vous emmènerai d'en démonter d'immeubles
où vous voyez des jeunes qui se
détruisent qui ont les yeux hagards qui
bavent
donc je dis c on est et nous sommes tous
ici dans une situation d' obligation de
résultat réponse de monsieur le maire la
promesse faite par le ministre de
l'intérieur une heure auparavant la
confirmation que d'ici des vacances nous
en sommes à commune la généralisation de
la police de proximité une police de
dissuasion et de prévention
michèle poncet institutrice n'est pas
contre pour elle c'est une partie de la
solution
on se sent plus ou moins abandonnée dans
le quartier on voit pas souvent la
police venir dans le sirh n'appuie
demain peut-être tant mieux et on verra
ce que ça va donner
il faut presque espérer et attendre agir
également lundi matin les écoles de
vénissieux seront à nouveau en grève